il ne se passe pas une semaine sans
qu'une femme soit agresser sans pouvoir
opposer la moindre résistance
et pourtant il existe des armes
défensives ou d'alarm capable de
désarmer ou de mettre en fuite
l'agresseur comme nous l'expliquent un
armurier oui ces armes d'ailleurs eux
sont de deux types
le premier type et larmes qui agit sur
la psychologie de la terreur éventuelle
du fait de leur ressemblance avec une
arme réelle
il s'agit soit du pistolet soit du
revolver d'alarmé
ces pistolets ou ses revolvers sont
susceptibles de tirer deux sortes de
munitions soit la munition détonante qui
agit par son bruit vous pour nous faire
découvrir un exemple vous donner un
exemple
le voici voyez vous voilà à briquet
quand même suffisamment important
puisqu'il est du même ordre que celui
d'un véritable pistolet calibre 6,35
comme nous en avons ici en voici un
voyez vous alors c'est grave et arras et
est un véritable piste de notre vue là
nous tirons pas ils peuvent agir
également pas l'adjonction d'une
cartouche de complément telle que celle
ci qui est une cartouche lacrymogènes
dans ce cas particuliers qu'il s'agisse
du revolver ou du pistolet la cartouche
lacrymogènes et à lui mais pas le départ
de la première cartouche détonante
il ya un deuxième type dame alors qu'il
a n'est plus seulement qui n'est pas
psychologiquement elle s'est au
contraire une arme essentiellement
efficace cet art qui simplement une
petite bombe contient du gaz lacrymogène
qui peut être projeté à g successifs et
super g qui peuvent d'ailleurs atteindre
un agresseur jusqu'à une distance de 2 m
à 2 m 50 et le mettre hors de combat
pour une durée variant de un quart
d'heure à deux heures environ et ce qui
est très intéressant et important c'est
qu'il n'ya aucune suite physiologique
par conséquent responsabilité civile nul
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
arm plus classiques traditionnels que
sont le sifflet à roulettes et le
parapluie je crois que le sifer à
roulettes au point de vue psychologique
est aussi sur le plan psychologique bien
entendu aussi efficace que le pistolet
car notre réflexe conditionné à tous et
en tendant un coup de sifflet roulettes
on a affaire évidemment un agent de la
force publique si le parapluie et bien
le parapluie je crois qu'il est beaucoup
moins efficace
beaucoup beaucoup moins efficace et la
chaussure à talon aiguille j'ai bien
fait tellement ils sont plus tellement
la wii mais leur live hervé comme un
cheval et ça je pense que c'est assez
difficile